Nevada's the last of the live and let live states.
I don't care if you smoke weed.
Don't bother me because I got a safe full of guns
and I'm in the sex business.
Hi I'm Zach Weissmueller  with Reason TV.
I'm here with Dennis Hof, owner and proprietor of the Moonlight Bunny Ranch
in Mound House Nevada.
He runs seven legal brothels in Nevada.
Dennis, thank you very much for joining us.
Glad you're here Zach, we're gonna have some fun today.
You brought the Bunny Ranch to prominance through various media outreach efforts
notably your collaboration with HBO for the Cat House series.
But this particular brothel has been around since at least the 1950s.
1955 it started here.
1955, so what got you into the business and how did you bring the Bunny Ranch to what it is today?